hi and welcome everybody I'm Christo's
and I'm joined here on stage by Whitney
boy and David and we're here to tell you
about how to resonate your voice can be
powerful
papiano you have a powerful voice can
you roar for me
voices travel much further than you ever
will and there are great leaders that we
can think of Winston Churchill
Baberaham Lincoln must meet the king
whose voices traveled right away around
the world and have inspired millions of
people to action even at times of truly
existential crisis those voices have
also changed the world and I know that
some of you guys have that same
attention to you guys from the cage
world right or you want to revolutionize
that you care bases and then Christie
wants to transform infrastructure in
Africa and so it's very important for
you guys to follow in the footsteps for
all the best in facts following the
footsteps of those great leaders I was
talking about by using your voices to
project engage and inspire there's only
one problem though because we're all
frequent audience member audience
members around here and it's difficult
to pay attention always to what people
are telling you when they're standing at
the front of a classroom some of you are
probably thinking about what's for
dinner tonight
others maybe about whether that hot guy
will give you a call back
he will JD he's your husband and so it's
very important that we we try and engage
the audiences who are who are attending
and listening to us we have to engage
and inspire them Whitney David and I are
here to give you four specific practical
tips about how you can engage your
audience those tips are on the board
behind me here you need to be able to
treat your audience as your hero
you need to be authentic you need to be
able to create star moments and last of
all you need to be able to abide by and
use a sparkline which we've already
heard about today but our team will will
define piu in a little bit so let's
start with the first one treating your
audience as a hero what does that
actually mean well I think to me it
means three particular things one it's
not actually about me it's about you
guys but about what you can do it's
about me treating you guys as me be
behaving as a mentor to you guys and I
think probably most importantly it's
about creating a glowing vision for you
of your future selves so now you know
your role you're the mentor you're yoda
and you're bringing your audience from
the old world into the new world how do
you do that we've learned so many
different tools and techniques on during
the course of this quarter and sometimes
it can feel pretty overwhelming I know
it is for me I want to tell you one
thing that if you can master this one
thing many of the other skills we've
been learning about will naturally flow
out of it and that's being authentic at
the beginning of this year I had just
started getting interested in startups
and entrepreneurship I was really
excited about this idea but it was also
really scared because I'm a really bad
communicator I get really nervous when
I'm standing in front of the audience
even in one-on-one meetings and so I
thought how can I be a leader when I
can't communicate and so I said so I
thought about this a lot does anyone
else ever feel this way get really
anxious yeah I realized that the reason
why we get anxious is actually really
simple we could anxious because we're
thinking about how other people how JD
how Burt how Allison are going to think
about what we're saying are you guys
gonna like me
authenticity deals with this problem
head-on authenticity is about knowing
and reflecting on what you believe
really becoming an expert in it and then
just sharing that comfortably and
confidently regardless of what other
people are gonna think the great thing
about authenticity is when you're
authentic you're naturally going to be
excited because you are your hand
gestures are gonna support where you're
saying and you're gonna bring in stories
because it's part of your story so the
challenge is how do you overcome that
fear how do you overcome that fear of
those awkward silences that just happen
now when you forget what you're saying I
think that one of the things that helped
me is this is a really tough question
for myself what happened for me was that
I realized that authenticity is actually
important not only in communication but
also in leadership and in
entrepreneurship I love this quote from
John doar
one of the big VCS at Kleiner Perkins he
says that great entrepreneurs and
leaders are missionaries and not
mercenaries authenticity is all about
being a missionary and not everyone is
going to like missionaries or like what
you're saying but missionaries are the
ones that are gonna change the world so
be yourself think about what you believe
share that confidently with your
audience and once you do that you're
ready to learn some other techniques you
can build on top of authenticity to
connect with your audience
so what David mentioned make me think
about a thought that I did five years
ago I was hiding behind the podium
talking about our investment that we
just did and I talked about everything
at about GDP I talked about how we come
really talk about how our business
partners I imported our sponsors I talk
about everything how we conquered the
world and I just went on and on I think
we all have been in this kind of
situation we are the audience in the
presentation just goes on and on then we
just wait for it to be over
we after it's over we actually don't
remember anything from it we've been in
that situation and today we heard so
many great presentations unfortunately
just 48 hours from now we'll forget
almost everything in fact we only
remember four slides out of a twenty
slide presentation in just two days will
forget 70% of the contents that we heard
today it's just human nature and because
our audience forgets so much it is so
important that they take away that one
message that is so important to take
away the one idea from your presentation
and in her book Nancy Duarte calls that
moment when you deliver that one idea
the star moment and she mentioned five
ways of delivering that star moment it
was firstly through powerful and
shopping centers days for example 30
million presentations are being given
every day how do you make yours
memorable it can be through emotive
visuals photos or videos for example it
can be through a model for storytelling
so we all remember Steve Jobs
speech about his products and how his
products can change the world
memorable dramatization how Bill Gates
pulls his job mosquitoes and releases to
the audience so that they feel the pain
of fighting with malaria and finally
reached repeatable sound bites and we
are all familiar with market Martin
Luther King's Speech of I have a dream I
have a dream I have a dream so
those are five ways of the delivering a
star moment and I have another five
suggestions I'd like to give you so that
you can make your Sam moment more
memorable and so those start with
simplicity your star moment has to be
simple because only simple messages can
be remembered
just a moment has to be transferable
because you have to be able to transfer
it to the audience it has to be audience
country something that resonates with
them and then it also has to be
repeatable so that your message can be
viral and you can they can transfer it
on after you and master it has to be
memorable
you want them to memorize that star
moment because we all remember that what
we are talking about it's so easily
forgotten so it is so important that
your message has Istanbul meant so that
they can deliver your message later on
so you keep the audience in mind as the
hero as you speak authentically as you
create star moments one additional piece
of tactical advice is to think about the
overarching trend of your storyline so
what Nancy Duarte
can call the spark line to effectively
engage your audience think about the
spark line trend you begin with a
baseline reality of what is and then you
oscillate with momentum by sharing
visions and inspirations of what can be
you can never eyes think of it as what
is terms of the caterpillar vision
versus what can be the butterfly vision
so let's assess our team's own
presentation as an example first I
started by sharing some experiences at
you and feelings you might feel when
you're disengaged in a presentation but
then by transferring ownership of the
hero status from the presenter to the
audience that that creates an emotional
bridge between the two
next David shared his own experience
with stress and anxiety when public
speaking but in in bringing his full
self his own self and speaking
authentically he is able to create an
emotional connection between himself and
the audience and finally we talked about
a speech that he gave that didn't quite
hit the mark didn't quite resonate been
creating a star moment he's able to
transfer the message from itself to you
and swing up with these tips we have
given you tactical advice on how you can
create a new reality for yourself as a
presenter to effectively resonate with
your future audiences so we'd like to
invite you the audience our heroes ask
questions that we can up shed light on